another new record for daily reported
cases with almost 190
000 being reported today that comes on
top of alarming figures released by the
office for national statistics which
estimates 2.3 million people in the uk
had covered 19 last week that's up from
1.4 million the previous week and it's
the highest number since comparable
figures began in autumn 2020.
the bulk of these that's more than 2
million were in england the equivalent
of around 1 in 25 people so how is that
spike in community transmission
translating into hospital admissions
in england the number of patients has
climbed to its highest level since
february
this shows the increase in admissions
over the last month
there were 2 370 on wednesday that's up
week on week and it's the highest number
since january the 29th
so the numbers in hospital are
increasing
but so are discharges so shorter stays
will take the pressure off that bed
occupancy
and to further put this into context
it's still way off the peak of the last
wave which saw more than 34 000 people
in hospital with covid
another reassuring bit of data is that
on critical care and the numbers of
patients on ventilators there has been a
small increase over the last week but
overall they are remaining relatively
stable but there is still a lot of
uncertainty about what lies ahead
you can see that we are heading into
um the um eye of the storm in terms of
the size of this peak we still don't
know
how big the peak is going to be how
quickly it will be over and the bit that
we're obviously particularly looking at
in the nhs is the number of older people
who require serious hospitalization and
there is a lot of concern about nhs
staffing as those high rates of
transmission impact workers more than 24
000 staff at nhs hospital trusts were
ill or self-isolating on boxing day
that's up 31 from the previous week and
nearly doubling since the start of the
month adding to the pressures already
being felt
another cause for concern is the latest
data on the effectiveness of vaccines
the uk health security agency has found
that astrazeneca has no effect against
omicron from 20 weeks after the second
dose while pfizer and modernist
protection waned to just 10 but with the
booster protection rises to almost over
80 a reminder of just how key the
booster is going to be to preventing a
serious wave overwhelming the nhs